good evening and thank you so much for
joining us tonight at six o'clock i'm
sasha loftis support for ukraine
continues here across the valley a rally
just wrapped up at city hall the group
has now moved to hennessey's tavern
madison kimbrough joins
at that us
madison
[Music]
a couple of supporters from the rally
earlier here at hennessey's tavern
supporting ukraine and the rally hosted
by the famous ukrainian figure skater
osana byul farina started around three
this afternoon around 100 supporters
from across the valley showed up wearing
the ukrainian flag colors of blue and
yellow many holding signs urging the end
to the war in ukraine this rally is a
continuation of the one that was held
last weekend on the strip local leaders
as well as bail farina spoke
passionately on ukraine's behalf here's
what some locals had to say about coming
out to today's rally
it's very personal we are calling every
day to make sure that you know our
family is still okay back there this is
our second protest our first one we were
crying
it was amazing to see like all these
different faces also like different
backgrounds different cultures
i mean the signs here are showing that
everybody supports us american not
american
ukrainian not ukrainian
[Music]
as for security metro was on standby in
case things got out of control but it
was peaceful rally leaders say they hope
to continue these peaceful gatherings
every weekend until some positive change
is done of course we plan on covering
this rally all through the evening
talking to some of the supporters that
are inside the restaurant as of now keep
it here at 6 30. we will be live here on
fremont reporting live madison kimbrough
live local now